The war that ended the world started on October
9th, 1971.
Tensions had been brewing for years between
America and the Soviet Union, and even though
people had done their best to keep a sense
of normalcy, everyone was wondering when the
Cold War that had been brewing for the past
30 years would boil over.
There were those who had been preparing for
it for years, while others assumed that it
would never amount to anything.
Neither nation wanted to make the first nuclear
strike, and even if that happened, the engineers
would come out of their underground cities
to intervene.
But nobody knew for sure if the two world
superpowers could ever come to an agreement,
or if it would all end in total destruction.
October 9th was the day that question was
answered.
The first American nuclear warhead detonated
over the Gulf of Finland, only a few miles
away from the city of Leningrad, where people
were going about their day blissfully unaware
of the destruction that was about to befall
them.
First came a city-wide blackout as the power
grid was bombarded with a huge surge of radiation
that caused bulbs to blow and wires to glow
like they'd been struck by lightning.
There was barely any time to react before
the next wave hit- a white-hot flash so bright
that many of those who couldn't get to cover
were blinded.
The third wave, by far the most destructive,
was the force of the explosion itself.
Like a powerful burning wind, it swept through
the city, breaking windows, knocking over
streetlights, ripping the leaves off of trees,
and bathing every car, building, and person
with ash.
People are trapped under the debris as some
of the city's older, less well-maintained
buildings come crumbling down.
Even though the Soviet government had been
preparing for this day to come and the Russian
people had been put through mandatory safety
drills, no amount of practice or planning
could've prepared them for the real thing.
The streets erupted into chaos- cars were
crashing into buildings, either because their
drivers had been blinded by the light of the
distant explosion or because the initial wave
of radiation had shorted the batteries.
People nearly trampled each other trying to
get to underground shelters as police and
military tried to yell directions over the
cacophony.
Among the crowd, a family desperately tried
to stay together.
Irina and Nikolai Belitrov held tight to their
children, Alexei and Tatiana.
The whole family was still in their pajamas
and barely had time to get their shoes on
before they started rushing towards the neighborhood's
designated underground bunker.
Irina had Tatiana, who was only two, clutched
tight to her chest, and Nikolai tried his
best to keep ten-year-old Alexei's eyes shielded
as they walked past the dead bodies of people
who were once their friends and neighbors.
“It'll be alright soon, son,” Nikolai
said, as much to try and convince himself
as his son, “We're going underground, just
like in the safety drills.”
Alexei nodded solemnly and kept his gaze straight
ahead.
They were almost at the end of the street,
when just above the sounds of air raid sirens
and screaming people, Alexei heard a familiar
voice.
“Alexei!
Alexei!”
The boy looked down to see his teacher, Mr.
Petrov, trapped in the wreckage of his car.
He must've been driving to work when the bomb
struck.
“Father, stop!”
Alexei yelled, tugging at his father's shirt
sleeve.
“That's my teacher, we have to help him,
or he won't make it to the shelter.”
“The soldiers will help him once everyone
else is in,” said Nikolai.
Alexei didn't listen.
He wriggled free of his father's grip and
ran to where his teacher lay pinned under
the wrecked vehicle.
Nikolai was calling after him, and though
Irina wanted to wait for Alexei to come back,
she was swept up in the tide of people and
separated from her husband.
Mr. Petrov was crying, thanking Alexei for
coming to his aid.
As Alexei got closer, he saw there was blood
pooling out from under the wreck- it seemed
if Mr. Petrov were going to make it out his
legs would likely be badly damaged.
Alexei tried to lift the car himself, but
even though he was strong for his age, he
was still only a child.
A soldier who had been helping people into
the bomb shelter stopped what he was doing
and ran over to Alexei.
“Hey, kid!”
the soldier shouted.
“Leave him alone and go back to your family-
you're going to hurt yourself.”
Alexei kicked and struggled against the soldier's
grip as he was dragged back into the line
with his family.
“But he's in trouble!”
Alexei cried.
“It's not your job to save him,” his father
scolded as he took his hand and led him down
the stairs where they would rejoin his mother
and sister.
As Alexei and his father descended into the
tunnels, Alexei heard a gunshot from the street
above.
Though he would survive long after that day,
he never saw his teacher Mr. Petrov again.
He never asked his father about what happened.
The Belitrov family was reunited in the underground
shelter, which had once been an underground
train station.
Tatiana had started crying, and Nikolai tried
desperately to quiet her.
Irina hugged her son so tight he felt she
might squeeze the life out of him.
They were packed in with a dozen other families,
some that they knew and others who were strangers.
Alexei recognized some of the other children
from school, and he saw that some were there
without their parents.
While they were in the station, a soldier
addressed the group and explained what would
happen next.
The train station was to serve as their temporary
shelter until the proper negotiations were
made with the engineers.
As per a treaty that had been written and
signed after the second world war, the engineers
had agreed to open the borders of their underground
civilization to humans fleeing from a crisis
above ground.
Once the government had made a decision, the
survivors were to be taken deep underground,
where they would live until the war was over.
Above ground, the Soviet Union began dealing
with the fallout of the initial attack.
It was clear that America could no longer
be dealt with reasonably if they were willing
to bomb one of the USSR's biggest cities.
Though the bombing had cut communications
between Leningrad and Moscow, eventually,
contact was re-established, and the army was
able to radio the Kremlin with a full report
on the damage.
Leningrad was in ruin, with over a third of
the population dead or otherwise too wounded
to move underground.
Those who had made it underground were receiving
treatment for everything from broken bones
and blindness to radiation poisoning.
In a word, it was chaos.
Russian parliament was quick and ruthless
in their decision to strike back.
On October 12th, Secretary Brezhnev authorized
nuclear missiles to be launched at both New
York City and Washington DC.
Millions were killed, and just like in Russia,
the survivors retreated underground.
America didn't go down without a fight, though,
and launched another missile attack, this
time at Moscow.
It wasn't long before both countries' allies
were involved in the conflict as well, with
missile strikes coming from France, China,
North Korea, Germany, and the United Kingdom.
Within a month, the surface of the Earth was
dangerously irradiated, and any humans who
were still living had retreated underground.
But though the world had ended, the war hadn't.
Alexei Belitrov and his family struggled to
adjust to their new life underground.
Though the engineers were intelligent and
human-like, their world was so different from
the world Alexei had lived in for the first
10 years of his life.
He barely ever saw them- the engineers were
nocturnal, sleeping while an artificial sun
nourished the genetically-engineered plants
that grew around the city.
But any time he tried to ask questions about
them, he was met with hushed silence by the
adults.
The engineers were spoken of in hushed, almost
reverent tones- they were the beings that
saved humanity, yes, but they had also helped
build the weapons that led to the war in the
first place.
Alexei barely had any time to settle into
this new life before what remained of the
Russian army started looking for new recruits.
Reports had come in from an above-ground scout
that the Americans were working on a new type
of armor that could fully shield the wearer
against radiation, and the Soviets couldn't
afford to be outmatched when their army was
still recovering from multiple nuclear attacks.
But the army wasn't asking for able-bodied
adult men to enlist- they were looking for
children.
“We can't possibly send our son to war,”
Irina said.
Arguments at the dinner table had become common
in the Belitrov family.
“He wouldn't be going to war,” Nikolai
argued.
“Not until their new anti-radiation technology
is perfected.
He won't be ready until he's an adult.”
“How do you know that what they're making
in those labs won't kill him?”
Irina said.
“Do we really want to trust these underground
devils with our son?
How much do we really know about the engineers,
anyway?”
“They could've let us all burn on the surface,”
Nikolai said, “but they didn't.
I think we should trust them.”
“I want to go,” said Alexei.
“I should.
Some of my friends have already enlisted.”
Both of his parents were stunned, but it made
sense to Alexei.
He wanted the war to be over, and he wanted
to leave the underground city.
But most importantly, he wanted to know if
anyone was still alive on the surface.
If there was even a sliver of a chance that
it could be habitable again, he wanted to
find out.
After much discussion, Irina and Nikolai agreed-
it was what was best for the future of Russia,
and, ultimately, the future of the human race.
Alexei's parents delivered him to the office
of army recruitment, and he was taken by a
man named Commander Volkov to a specialized
research facility.
This was when Alexei met an engineer for the
first time.
The engineer was tall and hairy, like a bear
walking on its back legs, but with a face
and hands more like a human's.
It was overseeing a group of humans and other
engineers as they tinkered with machines that
Alexei couldn't even begin to guess the purpose
of.
“Don't be frightened, Alexei,” Commander
Volkov said.
“They're going to explain the procedure
to you before you have to agree to anything.”
The engineer looked the boy over, then held
up a jar containing something that looked
like an insect's exoskeleton.
It was green, the same shade as the USSR's
army uniforms.
“This is our new bio-organic armor prototype,”
the engineer said.
“We can only graft it onto you while you're
still growing.
It must grow with you, starting on your back,
then moving to your limbs, then your head.”
Alexei was frightened by the idea but didn't
want to seem weak.
He wanted to make sure his father would be
proud of him.
He was taken into surgery, where the team
of engineers and human doctors grafted the
plate of bio-organic armor onto his spine.
Once the surgery was over, he was wheeled
into a recovery room, where he was fed a simple
meal alongside all of his friends and classmates.
They'd all gone through the same procedure.
Over the next eight years, Alexei and his
comrades went through the painful process
of growing their exoskeleton.
Like the engineer had said, it grew with them,
but the growth happened in painful spurts
rather than gradually.
The worst thing about the armor was that it
couldn't be removed.
But it gave them many advantages to normal
soldiers, as well.
Once it covered Alexei's legs, he found he
could jump higher and run farther than any
human normally could.
When it grew over his arms, it gave him increased
strength.
By the time he was eighteen, it had covered
his head, giving it a fly-like appearance
but also granting him stereoscopic vision
and the ability to hear radio transmissions
without the need for any other communication
device.
During this time, he and the other boys were
trained by Commander Volkov, learning how
to use the powers granted to them by their
exoskeletons for combat.
When they were deemed ready, they were all
outfitted with shoulder cannons, supply packs,
and guns, all of which were also bio-organic
and were surgically attached.
It had been eight long years since the end
of the world, and Alexei was now able to set
foot back on the surface.
The world he returned to was almost unrecognizable-
there were no signs of life outside of weeds
and vines overtaking the irradiated ruins
of buildings.
Within the first hour of returning to the
surface, Alexei gave up any hope of finding
survivors.
He heard Volkov's voice barking orders through
the suit- there was no time to reminisce about
the past.
The soldiers had a job to do.
Want an anomaly of your own?
Check out www.scpswag.com for high-quality
SCP merch!
Now go check out “SCP-2273 - Major Alexei
Belitrov” and “What Actually Happened
to Major Alexei Belitrov?
SCP-2273 - Tale” for more from the story
of this interdimensional soldier!